what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and the finale for
She-Hulk has just dropped and it was
quite different than a lot of people
including myself thought that it would
actually be but it did set up a lot for
the future of the MCU specifically the
Hulk now we know a Hulk movie is
confirmed to be coming on the way so
this not only confirmed it in the series
as well but gives us a little bit of an
Insight of what we could actually see
now right away let me know what you
thought about she-hulk's finale and the
series as a whole in the comments down
below and of course if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe today we'll
be going over the ending and talking
about what it sets up and through the
week we'll be talking about She-Hulk and
other things that the series set up
including if we are going to be seeing
Jennifer Walters again now just like
She-Hulk in the comics She-Hulk in the
series is a character that breaks the
fourth wall and that actually ended up
being a pretty big plot point for this
finale now the last episode episode 8
left off with intelligencia kind of
exposing Jennifer Walters this caused
her to get angry and she kind of went
into She-Hulk rage mode and this because
the dodc to come and unfortunately as
this episode begins we find out that
repercussions came from She-Hulk hulking
out also I should add spoiler alert for
the season finale of She-Hulk we're
about to dive into them so you've been
warned now there were obviously some
really big things at the end of this
finale then they were kind of Rewritten
and then some more really big things
happened and then some more big things
happened again with Hulk appearing with
his son scar just like we thought it
would and they actually did confirm that
Hulk is getting a solo movie we'll talk
about that in just a bit now sadly jyn
wakes up in a prison her co-workers are
there and they tell her that basically
she has to take a plea deal to where she
can't turn into She-Hulk again she loses
her job she has to move back home and
then eventually goes to Emil's Retreat
Nikki using a bro account gets an invite
to an I hate She-Hulk party and she gets
the help of pug to be her bro there they
find out that Todd is indeed the villain
and the founder of intelligencia
abomination was missing from the resort
and Jen tries to track him down and as
it turns out he's been taking public
speaking deals as the Abomination
however it is important to note that he
did not take this deal because he hates
Jennifer Walters or She-Hulk he did it
simply for the money now from here a
pretty predictable finale starts to
happen or so they would have you think
Todd AKA Hulk King reveals that he hired
Josh not only to get a sex tape of
She-Hulk but to also get her blood so
what does he do of course he injects
himself with her blood turning into a
Hulk himself Jennifer breaks the fourth
wall several times during the scene
where she says this isn't actually
happening right this isn't how the
finale is going down Titania also shows
up busting through the wall again Todd
goes to attack Jennifer but Abomination
picks her up because like I said it
wasn't because he hated She-Hulk that he
was speaking it was simply a gig for
money he actually does care about her as
a friend so he does try to protect her
however right as he's protecting her
Bruce Banner busts in from the ceiling
sees that Abomination is holding
Jennifer effort and says get away from
my cousin and the two of them start to
fight this is where jyn yet again breaks
the fourth wall and says that this is
all too messy and these stories don't
make any sense she then breaks the
fourth wall again looking directly at us
and asks is this working for you and
from here they try to make it seem like
you accidentally went back to the Marvel
Disney plus home screen which is very
clever for a second I kind of did think
that I exited out of the She-Hulk series
for some reason but then of course I
realized what was happening we can hear
Jennifer say this menu isn't going to
stop me and she says just gonna break
this inhibitor real quick talking about
the inhibitor that was put on her ankle
to prevent her from turning into
She-Hulk she breaks it off and then we
see She-Hulk bust through the thumbnail
for the She-Hulk series she sees Marvel
Studios assembled and she goes through
that and where does she end up in the
real world and Marvel Studios when she
first gets there we can hear two people
talking in the background one says so
tell me about The Infinity Gauntlet it's
amazing the other man says so back when
we were working on the first Thor movie
they had come to me and asked me to make
a gauntlet and this is kind of making
fun of Marvel Studios because that's
kind of what She-Hulk does it's a very
self-aware show it breaks the fourth
wall and this is specifically talking
about in the first Thor movie in Odin's
Vault we actually saw an Infinity
Gauntlet however in Thor Ragnarok hella
would go on to reveal that it was fake
now eventually She-Hulk makes her way to
a door that says She-Hulk production so
she goes in and basically sees the round
table of everybody that was working on
the show and again they start to address
things that people say in the real world
She-Hulk says this is stupid but the
writers are saying that there are
certain things that are supposed to
happen in a superhero story She-Hulk
says why don't we do things a different
way and the writers say this is the
story that Kevin wants and they are
referring to Kevin feige the president
of Marvel Studios She-Hulk says okay
then I want to talk to Kevin there's a
brief pause and then everybody starts to
laugh obviously this is a big joke about
Kevin foggy being the big dog at Marvel
Studios of course he is the president
they start to say nobody talks to Kevin
and they even start defending him saying
I'll kill you before you get to Kevin
however she just kind of goes to his
office and what's really interesting is
that this is really Kevin feige's office
this is what it looks like Iron Man in
the back and all they make a joke that
she has to sign an NDA before she goes
in to see him which everybody has to do
it's called a non-disclosure agreement
basically it says that if you reveal
anything that is talked about or
anything that you see at Marvel Studios
you will get sued however they call
Security on her but she's she-hulks so
she goes right through them eventually
she makes it to Kevin's office and we're
all expecting to see Kevin feige however
the Kevin that we see is very different
It's actually an AI robot called Kevin
which is an acronym for knowledge
enhanced visual interconnectivity Nexus
in which in all honesty is still
basically describing Kevin feige now
there's some jokes here where they ask
her to change back into Jennifer Walter
she asks why they say because it's
expensive to have CGI She-Hulk but Kevin
also said says however don't turn back
into Jennifer Walters on screen wait
till they cut away so the CGI doesn't
have to show her transforming back to
Jennifer therefore they could save money
now from here it gets super meta the
show was already pretty meta but here it
really gets into it Jennifer says that
the ending for the finale sucks and it
should be changed and she makes her
closing argument to Kevin of why it
should actually change and she says it's
often said that Marvel movies all in the
same way this is obviously coming from
The Real World from critics and simply
fans and haters that have said many
times before that Marvel movies in the
same way Jennifer says perhaps it's a
result of following some Unwritten rule
that you have to throw a bunch of plot
and Flash and a whole blood thing that
seems super suspiciously close to Super
Soldier Serum at the audience in the
climax and then she says I propose we
don't have to do that and from here Jen
essentially rewrites the finale Todd
doesn't turn into a Hulk nothing
essentially happens with Titania Brie
spanner doesn't appear to save the day
and here is where we get our big
confirmation for the Hulk movie Jin says
he doesn't have to return but Kevin says
while he was supposed to return to
explain what he was doing on sakarp
however jyn interrupts and says we don't
need to hear all that think Kevin says
but we were going to introduce and then
Jen interrupts again and says save it
for the movie confirming to us that the
Hulk is getting a movie and we are going
to find out what he did on sakar and of
course we were introduced to his son
scar more on him in just a bit she says
Abomination should be held accountable
for his actions and she wouldn't mind
seeing Daredevil again then Jen sits
down and starts poking fun at some
characters for having daddy issues
however she does ask Kevin when are we
getting the X-Men then she looks at the
camera gives us a thumbs up and sticks
her tongue out and this is great because
this is obviously Marvel telling us hey
we know you want to know about the X-Men
I will say they added a pretty clever
joke where jyn says that's what hulks do
we smash things Bruce smashes buildings
I smash fourth walls and Bad Endings and
sometimes Matt Murdock Kevin also makes
a joke that we'll see her on the big
screen implying that she's going to get
her a movie she asks really and he says
no so when they were talking about save
it for the movie that was indeed about
Hulk and not She-Hulk now from here
things just kind of wrap up Todd is
putting handcuffs he's taken away Jen
says I'll see you in court Titania seems
to be kind of friendly towards Jen now
Daredevil shows up not to save the day
because he's a little too late but
because Jen wanted to back and let's
face it we all did and Emile goes back
to prison for 10 years that is until the
post credit scene now the last scene is
of Jen at her family's house with Matt
Murdock there as well and her family is
grilling him for being a lover of gin
they asked him how much money he makes
and he says he works in Hell's Kitchen
does a lot of pro bono work and is
heading back there in a week and then of
course Bruce Banner slash Professor Hulk
comes in and he says I know I've been
away on sakkar for a while I'll tell you
all about it but first I have someone
here that I'd like you all to meet this
is my son Scar and we called it from the
very first episode we were talking about
how scar is most likely going to appear
in either the Hulk movie or in She-Hulk
we figured that when a sakarian ship was
trying to get a hold of Hulk not
actually attack him but get a hold of
him to deliver a message that it was
friendly and most likely about his son
in the comics Hulk goes to sakar well I
should say that he is tricked by the
Illuminati to go into space and then
ends up on sakar where he ends up
becoming Gladiator Hulk which we did see
in Thor Ragnarok on zakar but what we
didn't see in Ragnarok that does happen
in the comics is that he ends up ruling
sakar he ends up marrying kyera and she
gets pregnant with his son however
unfortunately the ship that the
Illuminati sent him there blows up and
ends up killing Kaira and his unborn son
or so he thought Hulk in his full rage
in the world war Hulk storyline returns
to Earth to seek Vengeance on those that
sent him there the Illuminati The
Avengers the X-Men and the Fantastic
Four however unbeknownst to him thanks
to some powers from his mother scar
actually lived and here's where things
get kind of interesting because they
can't go the exact story from the comics
in the MCU because things aren't exactly
set up the right way for starters we
don't have the Illuminati we don't have
the X-Men or the Fantastic Four in the
MCU yet and we also don't really have
the Avengers right now and two something
that could be a plot point but most
likely won't be at this point in time is
that scar actually tries to kill Hulk
when he's first introduced in the comics
now eventually scar finds out that the
Hulk isn't the same Hulk so therefore he
doesn't want to kill him anymore and
that could happen here in the Hulk film
now for those who are not aware it has
been reported that a solo Hulk film is
in the works and it is going to be based
off of the world war Hulk storyline now
like I mentioned and just described this
takes place on zakar and what's
important to know here is that Bruce
Banner and Professor Hulk were not the
same as the Hulk that we got in Ragnarok
in fact when Bruce Banner finally
transformed into himself from the Hulk
he didn't realize what was happening and
he thought that they were still during
the events of Avengers Age of Ultron he
asked about sokovia about Nat about the
Avengers and Thor had to explain to him
that it was years ago and that he's been
the Hulk for two years so here's what
happened the Hulk had a baby not Bruce
Banner the Hulk but Bruce is now dealing
with the aftermath of that and the
aftermath of that is his son scar who is
going to play a key role in the Hulk
solo film which I'm assuming is going to
come sometime in phase six unless they
are planning to do it after Secret Wars
which I would be shocked in then it will
come in Phase 7. now for the
post-credits scene it's pretty simple
Juan comes and gets a meal out of prison
since Emile Blonsky slashed the
Abomination helped Wong during his
challenge to become sorcerer Supreme
Wong offered a male Sanctuary at the
sanctum so this is him holding true to
his original deal for a meal now Emil
does make a joke that Wong is kind of
late and took his time probably because
he was in another TV show so I would
expect to see Wong in another Disney
plus series from Marvel pretty soon and
that's it for the ending explained in
the post-credits scene explained for
She-Hulk episode 9 the finale and of
course like I said we'll be breaking
down the finale even more later on this
week but again let me know what you
thought about the finale and the series
as a whole in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU you can
always follow me on Twitter and
Instagram for live updates and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
foreign